dr vivek das will be enlightening us for
this knowledge on role of bioinformatics
in the present era of high throughput
biology digital health and drug
discovery
and let me introduce dr gravey
he was born and raised in india in the
city of joy kolkata vivek das doctor has
been quite the wanderer having lived in
various parts of the country and the
world from having a bachelor's degree in
biotechnology from bangalore university
masters in biomedics from bit mestra
ranchi iga programmer analyst job he did
in cognizant kolkata he holds a psg our
reports talking cancer computational
biology from ieo milan an industry
postdoc at novo nordisk seattle
dr vivek's professional career has a
global footprint presently a doctor
provides passion brought him to denmark
where he is the computational biology
senior research scientist at
bioinformatics and data mining
department in novo nordisk he is
involved in biomarker and target
discovering chronic diseases using in
silico approaches his present work
involves crunching big data from bulk
single cell multi-omics along with
phenotypic measurements that need
careful integration of interdisciplinary
knowledge from biology computer science
mathematics and statistics he also
explores the application of advanced
statistical machine learning and deep
learning models in high dimensional
single cell multi-omics for particular
problems scopes given the data bandwidth
as a part of some of his curiosity
driven research activities
and last but not least his hobbies
include science communication remote
mentoring blogging traveling functional
training hiking and reading
and for more you can follow him on
australian profile
i'm excited to hear to your talk sir we
all are indeed over to you
thank you thanks for the kind
introduction uh can you hear me
yes we can hear you
yes so i'll try to share myself
can you see my slider
yes we can see us
okay um thank you everyone and thanks
for having me here uh for the
day two of the omics recent symposium um
data and life science uh getting
involved in the impact
um today i will speak about the role of
bioinformatics in present terror of high
throughput biology digital health and
drug discovery and what a kind of work
i've been doing at november and some of
the gigs that i've been doing outside as
a part of my creative curiosity driven
research
um so
before going ahead i just want to you
know present uh what's the perspective
of how do people see bioinformatics as a
computational biologist
and there are different aspects a
different perspective how people see us
um
it's sometimes very amazing very funny
uh and i i you know
would encourage everyone to actually
think like how bioinformatics is
perceived in today's world it's a very
exciting field actually and you must
have all seen how how actually everybody
has explained what its role is so i will
i will just put some flavors of um
how i see it and how i've been using it
i basically am this person who is
basically
doing stuff with data these datas are
generated in-house from different you
know therapy areas different you know
biological scientists or from public
level resources and then i used you know
algorithms or methods that are already
developed or we are developing in-house
to crunch these data in a way that we
can make normal discoveries out of it
that can help us to you know realize uh
early drug targets or even biomarkers
for onset of the disease or even you
know
disease progression but the overall goal
is to actually feed them into these four
cornerstones of uh medicine which is
prediction prevention personalization
and participation this is the four
corners that i think
uh bioinformatics you know is slowly
emerging as a as a leading into the
disciplinary field
moving ahead i would first like to see
uh to give an overview of uh why what i
i do as a scientist in our department
novel not disc
we are a
big pool of uh 30 plus people now across
three multiple sites at nominations i
belong to the bioinformatics and data
mining team
and uh which stand on four of these four
pillars uh we serve multiple therapy
area rnds we serve uh different research
technologies where we provide different
biofilmic solution we also serve uh you
know providing
solutions to understand mechanism of
actions uh
by using uh
leveraging the potential of sequencing
in clinical trials we are trying to
understand where clinical uh sequencing
can help to uh to get better
understanding of mechanistic studies uh
in clinical trials we have some
new trials that we are using the role of
sequencing more
singles sequencing then we also you know
working in translational medicine but
what we do basically in all these four
pillars are early drug target
identification
building analytical workflows for target
evaluation that can be you know a very
fantastic target that comes from
literature from particular chronic
disease areas
or data visualization because
as a part of informatics we also often
try to you know provide solutions where
biologists can you know
figure out
gene names how they are changing across
disease cohorts or or you know single
cell
maps and what so so on so forth and then
we do a lot of biomarker identification
yes and doctor vivek i'm so sorry to
interrupt it between but uh your voice
is not that clear can you
please check
my sorry um i'll try to increase my
volume uh can you hear me now
yes okay now
okay
okay i apologize for that
so
yeah great thanks
so what we basically do is we use
various public and internal uh orbics
data uh example you know blood transfer
atomics proteomics metabolomics genetics
epigenomics or single islamics taken all
together
analyze them mostly from human and in
and also in vitro in your settings to
derive biological insights i have
highlighted the part human is because we
follow approach in our pipeline which is
more human centric what that does mean
is we start from human data we derive
insights we find you know specific uh
targets or biomarkers and then we try to
understand what setting of different
individual can help us to reach
the
clinical phase so that's why we start
with human data and we have a very uh
scalable pipeline across
the human-centric value
now i will go more into the details of
the talk uh the outline is divided in
three parts what is bioinformatics in
time of high throughput biology and
digital health why is bioinformatics
important in drug discovery and what is
the future state and aspirations of
modern medicine now these are all my own
personal perspectives and opinion based
on my experience and so it might not
always align with everyone but this is
how i see the field and how i see the
role of bioinformatics in a
pharmaceutical setting as and beyond
so what is my informatics in the time of
high throughput biology now modern
medicine and biology has gone a
tremendous improvement in evolution i
would say it's a revolution
in current
age where we have so much of high
throughput you know technologies where
we can measure
different modalities uh from you know we
can do imaging we can understand tissues
and
composition we can do genotyping we can
actually also leverage the powerful
omics like genomics transcriptomics
proteomics
not only from organs but our tissues or
cells but also in vitro settings or in
vivo settings all these taken together
when we sequence them we can actually
build up a map or network
at a cellular level right and these when
put into sequencing machines can
actually build a huge information
complex of multi-omics
in information that can help us to tease
out the different molecular uh features
which can help which when integrated
properly can help us to understand the
disease progression of the or the kind
of disease drivers
and and what this gives us actually to
help us to understand
how does the central dogma of molecular
biology work i consider that as the
hottest science in town basically
because it helps us to understand the
basic foundations of the entire uh
molecular journey
and this is still the key to understand
any development of disease biology
and sequencing
high throughput sequencing of different
types of uh omics can actually do this
what it does is basically it tries to
accrue all these information from
different
organs or tissues or cells from the
human system
a true or let's say uh you know build uh
or
achieve the information from each type
of different molecules together
stitch them with the information that we
get from the clinical notes or the
imaging
put them together with suitable models
or methods
but in the end it's trying to derive the
relationship between the genotype and
phenotype and once we get this
information we can actually better
understand a disease footprint
now why is bioinformatics important in
drug discovery
now medicine over the years have been
undergoing some paradigms what does
paradigm shift means here we know that
one-size-fits-all theory in medicine
doesn't work not every every therapy
works with for everyone some have you
know benefits some don't some even have
adverse events so we have been seeing a
change from stratified to a more precise
medicine and what precision medicine is
actually ensuring is trying to say we
can deliver the right intervention
to the right patient at the right time
and how this can be done this can be
done with individual patient level
information that can actually you know
take information from genomics and other
comics
you know club them with the different
information of lifestyles their
preferences their health records and
medical history
all taken together so that we can
deliver a very tailored therapeutics to
each patient
and this is the dream where what where
the medicine is actually going and most
of our you know uh
industry are also trying to understand
how we can actually implement this in
our system when we are trying to
generate new drugs on new therapeutics
and another part is over the years we
have also learned that the drug
development journey is actually
very very slow and expensive
a lot of candidates fail not every drugs
have great effects most of managing
marginal so this poses problems right
because it's a huge investment so for us
it's very important now that we need to
have
much more clear and effective solutions
and how can we do that with the help of
sequencing or omics where when we talk
about bioinformatics bioinformatics come
from fact that we are able to sequence
or you know have omics information from
different layers
of the molecular biology right and each
of these plates has its own specific
roles to contribute to any kind of
biomarker and drug target discovery in
any kind of disease understanding or
development of biology understanding as
you can see from this slide taken
together with any kind of clinical
information
now when we take together all these
information we have to be also very
efficient of what models and methods we
are using right if we are talking that
we want to develop biomarkers or drug
targets now this whole thing is called
era of omics medicine and i i find it
very enriching that over the years
due to
how the field has emerged how our you
know scholars in the academic field has
helped us this has become now very
important
component also in the pharmaceutical
industry
and we are now joining this journey as
well
some of the applications of omega driven
medicine where bioinformatics feed into
is population genetics and genomics some
of you might heard about you know single
liquid polymorphism or genomic
association studies that forms into this
then development of biology learning or
disease biology learning uh using
different kind of multiomics of organs
tissues and cells longitudinal studies
are cross-sectional geomics
and then
early drug discovery and therapeutics i
have highlighted some of the disease
areas that we work in at novo ones that
are bold are the ones where i contribute
and i work and i give my
scientific expertise
however
all these are great
but these are all mostly done in a
population of cells a population that
was not having the information of
cellular resolution
these lack that cell level information
because we were always looking into in a
more holistic manner where all the
effect of these cells were actually
averaged up
a human body is complex as we know as we
are learning now of some new
technologies that have emerged in the
last few years that our system has
actually trillions of cell and some
share commonalities and some do not and
that's when the era of the singles and
technologies emerged right
and one of the exciting example of this
was this uh new treatment that came out
uh from uh from the consortium of the
human lung selectors where they are able
to for now create and map
uh a big uh human cell atlas
human cell lung atlas around that maps
around over 2 million cells from 440 for
individual now this is a massive task
that has been done by some brilliant
scientists uh from the
uh in the field that has
used you know bioinformatics that have
used biology that have used interest
discriminate computer science
mathematics and statistics and machine
learning all together to understand
what are the different you know cell
types that are involved
in in any disease setting
when we are having when we are looking
into the lungs what are the cell types
that are affected by variants what are
the what are the effects of age smoking
and pmi whatsoever so this is one of the
biggest tasks that was that came out
recently and this is a wonderful example
of of the single cell technology
however these kind of high throughput
work is also very complex because it
builds a huge
information complex it helps it runs us
into the problem of dimensionality curse
overfitting
any kind of you know linear non-linear
structure and lack of generalizability
why because we are talking about matrix
like big tables where big tables is
composed of multiple dimensions these
dimensions comes from features that can
be your genes proteins metabolites and
across your observations and
observations in the bulk setting is your
patients animal samples but when you
think of single cells it's each cell
coming from all these information right
so that's a huge information complex
and this is often very challenging and
this is where bioinformatics is
challenging right and i have discussed
about it in a in a systematic review
uh in 2020 where i tried to stress that
how multiomics field work should be done
what are the you know caveats what are
the pros what are the cons and what we
need when we want to start on embark on
this journey and then in single cell
field also there are amazing uh paper
out there which also
speaks about what are the different
challenges in these
pertaining to the data science because
when we talk about these into this high
dimensional interdisciplinary field we
know that it comes with its own caveats
and these caveats some of them can be
data sparsity data heterogeneity
non-flexibility of the statistical
frameworks the missingness of the data
and then integration
we we can tackle some of these but
they're not that easy
how we can is if we can build tools that
are well benchmarked or systematically
you know check with other computing
tools we we can solve some of these
problems but there's a lot of work that
needs to be done there there not every
problems have been tackled some of them
that we have mentioned in these papers
but not everything so there's a lot of
scope of research out there and
bioinformatics has to you know play a
lot of role in this
now here what i'm trying to say is apart
from the work i do as a part of the
scientist
for the company i work for novo artists
i also sometimes you know do work with
certain students back in india
where i you know put my brains in some
curiosity driven projects
and as a part of these prop projects i
think about problems uh in method
development for bulk multimix
integration as you can see here on the
left then i'm very fascinated by the
concept of single cell technologies and
how by hydrogen biology in forms of
single cell is such a big data in terms
of the dimensionality and
and this often begs me to question
what are the best way to actually
squeeze those high dimensional data in a
small ligand representation so that it's
human readable human uh can understand
and make derived insights from it and
that's where the you know the concepts
of dimension reduction air methods and
you know clustering kicks in and then
when we look into these single cell
we have to have
have those single cell in specific
clusters and this cluster is to have
certain identity and these are not very
easy tasks because when you're talking
about labeling those clusters identity
where the group of cells comes together
which means that we are trying to say
that that identity belongs to a specific
biology and we call them as cell type
labels and i've been also been thinking
around those problems quite uh for for
quite quite some time mostly on the on
the
mathematical side like how we can get
better at those cell type labeling so
these are some of the curiosity
different problems that i have been also
working uh as a part of my
site projects uh two of them i've
highlighted and i will share a bit of
those work in the next slides uh one is
how to better integrate multi-mix data
by improving future extraction issues
and can we improve singles and notation
using a better embedding method
the first one is
based on multiomics
here in 2020 i grew i teamed up with a
few researchers back in india
where i try to understand can i estimate
a gene expression function
uh from dna inhalation which is an
epigenomic information and copy number
variation at protein coding region
and we came up with a you know a method
of feature extraction we thought that
this is an issue of feature extraction
at high dimension
uh we came up with a method that
involves uh deep digitizing our auto
encoder and multi-layer perceptron and
we tipped together we were able to see
if we integrate this information from
you know dna collision and copy number
can we estimate uh mrna and if we can
estimate this mrna how good is that
estimate from the real uh data and we
used uh
you know liver hepatocellular cancer
carcinoma data from the cancer genome
atlas that had
over 400 patients data and it was
exciting to see that when we were able
to actually build a model we were able
to predict uh the the
observed rna values as good as the real
ones but that does not end the story
right when you build a model it's also
important how good your model is uh when
it's being tested with every other
existing models that are out there and
when we did that we benchmarked
systematically a different
regularization hyper parameter uh how
our model is working we found that our
model was actually working as one of the
top models we did in three different
variants and one of the variants of the
model which was working uh came out as
uh as one of the top with the least
error so this was very encouraging uh
for me to think how multiomics
as a feature extraction issue can be
actually improved
next uh i i wanted to stress a bit on my
single cell work that i've been doing
how i'm thinking about the field and
where the problem scopes are same but
before that i want to
say that single cell field is massive
there's a lot of work uh one can do it's
beyond what we did with bulk or mix or
bulk multi-omics we can get information
both at cell level and at gene level
which was usually we often did at gene
level when we were looking into always
the multi-omics right we did you know
differential expression gene search in
regular networks but now we can add
another layer of information we can
actually understand what is the
trajectory of a disease what is this
different states of these what cell
states are involved what are the
composition of those and what are the
clusters that we can derive from when we
are actually sequencing these uh cell
populations
i am particularly interested in two uh
problems as at this moment where i'm
trying to think uh single cell problem
scopes based on clustering and cell cell
cluster annotation and uh recently uh
one of the work uh that
i have worked with uh
with two researchers back in india got
accepted um
it will be out in the next week in
online uh where i thought of the cell
type annotation uh using single cell
data as a problem embedding what i
thought was like given we have these you
know huge data matrices of cell and gene
what if if i think of this uh problem of
you know cell type labeling or
clustering or notation whatever you may
say more as a problem of cell embedding
or and uh you know clustering so we came
up with an approach where we tried to
use a
non-negative macro fraction
factorization to uh diameter to redu to
reduce the dimension of the data of
these you know cell position matrices
across different samples and then try to
understand if we can then additionally
use
recursive k-means to cluster the data
and we can actually define the cell
types from limited labels that we
already have from the data and in fact
uh this was this we tested on like
six or seven to eight different uh data
sets that are publicly available thanks
to the research community
and when we did any kind of accuracy in
performance we saw that we our method
was working very well
interestingly what we also did was we
randomly then you know missed out the
real labels that were available with the
data to understand
how well there are cluster similarities
and we found that our methods was
actually having a very high cluster
similarity as you can see from the era
indexes
for each of these datasets now again as
i always say i'm a big fan of you know
systematically benchmarking i always
think that why will someone use my
method if i'm not actually you know
looking at its performance with anyone
uh any other methods
so i took a step back and then i tried
to understand well now given that we
have seen that it is performing well how
does this perform with you know existing
semi-supervised method or uh your
unsupervised method and here there are
some representative images where where i
was able to see that our method was
actually performing uh very well in more
than uh five data sets out of six
uh when compared to another
semi-supervised method that was recently
published called color
as you can see from the accuracy plots
and then i compared uh the cluster
similarity using uh
against
an unsupervised method called zero which
is very popular in this uh single cell
field i was able to find that at least
for fifty percent of the data set our
method was as good as jura
and uh but it was good across almost all
the data sets apart from one from the
other semi-supervised method
then in
additionally
i actually also we also actually tested
uh the method
for intra and inter cluster dispersion
with two data sets that were uh
downloaded from the european
bioinformatics institute server
where there were real missing
annotations when i say real missing
annotation means these data sets had
a cloud of you know cells
which did not have actually any kind of
cell type information so we wanted to
see whether we can redefine using our
method
uh that those data sets and can we
actually define get cell classes out of
it and when we did that we found that
our method was actually outperforming uh
the you know the syrah at that time so
this was very encouraging for us that
looking the of the cell type problem as
a problem of you know embedding and
clustering you're able to come with us
very efficient simple
scalable method
so here i'm now progressing to the end
part of my slide the last slides are
future state of aspirin and aspirations
of modern medicine
i see that medicine is actually
going interdisciplinary in terms of
cell-based intercepting
why because now we have
a huge explosion of you know single cell
data and single-celled multi-year mix of
single data means a lot of you know
advanced statistical and machine
learning methods because the data
dimension is huge
and and this also means we are also
getting better at understanding
orthogonal you know experimental thesis
models but this is great future for us
because now we are trying to go in a
high dimensional era of medicine where
we are trying to understand the disease
trajectory from healthy to different
type of disease being neurological
cancer or you know
chronic but we can actually understand
one cell at a time how the disease is
evolving and we can actually detect
early which can actually understand this
uh the molecular mechanisms and actually
you know get better new drug targets and
these are these can all happen if we can
efficiently use bioinformatics
so here i come to my last slide
uh i hope i was able to convey how
bioinformatics is actually you know
helping the modern medicine and
biology
all these informations that we are
trying to accrue these days using
molecular special molecular astrological
anatomical
this is
a huge abundance of data
these are
you know high dimensional data
but the overall goal is to
take all these different modalities
together
build up integrated you know cell
phenotypic map that can be multi-scale
multimodal
which can actually help us to understand
the
underlying phenotype of the cell and
when we understand the phenotype the
cell we can better understand the states
that can be the epigenomic states the
cellular interaction the tissue
organization you know and the
identification of some sometimes news or
the cell type which eventually can help
us to understand disease mechanisms
interactions you know signatures and new
biomarkers
all and
overall can help in designing leaner
clinical trials
which can improve personalized medicine
and eventually also help us building
you know better improved drugs
so this is how i see the field of
bioinformatics contributing to the
modern medicine
and i hope
i was able to share some of the thoughts
with you all
and i thank
everyone who has been instrumental in
providing and guiding me with the
scientific knowledge i thank my
department for supporting me and my
collaborators
and
i hope uh you guys had
had a good time and this was a very nice
conference that i really enjoyed every
everything uh about it
so i hope
you you had also some
uh you know
curiosity driven
questions so feel free to ask and i'm
happy to take more questions
thank you so much for the presentation
it was very
uh christian shot and giving an overall
view about how these different types of
uh techniques are important and what
bioinformatics
role is in all of these studies we have
a question by just pete score she's
asking what is the first step to begin
with by learning biomathematics and data
mining what basic skills are needed to
start with and please mention accessible
sources
so i would say that uh
my field uh my growth has been i started
as a as a biologist and then i you know
went on to computer science
uh i always see that uh it's important
to
pick up you know soft skills so
programming
and
and you know a bit of mathematics the
way the field is progressing you one
would need a bit of more understanding
mathematics i would always say to pick
up
programming and mathematics or
statistics a bit more if you want to
venture in in the modern bioinformatics
uh and the biology is important but that
you can
learn over the line there are some
resources i can share it's uh if if i
get an email there are some very
available free resources that is there
from swiss institute of mathematics i
keep sharing some resources on my
linkedin profile as well so you know
yeah i would be happy to share them
offline
to the group here
all right so we also have to have a
thorough resources and we'll be able to
share as well
yeah thank you so much sir and the next
question is what are the applications in
digital health and how are they being
employed in the process of drug
discovery what are your thoughts about
it yes that's a great question i didn't
touch much on the digital health but
what i'm trying to portray is when we
consider digital health the digital
health can be you know wearables
measurements from the variables but
pressures right and these can be done
from your smart watches
and and these are often your snapshot
and they are these days uh taken also
into account when you're talking to your
doctors
now how it will be used in a day-to-day
it's still an open research problem fda
has not yet approved everything uh we we
don't know how it is going to improve
but having a blood pressure you know acg
ekg from your wearables
that's already a great data point for
you to improve your lifestyle so you can
always improve your lifestyle on that
front in bioinformatics it's still very
early
but but there are some trials going on
so we will learn more about it in in
future at this moment i would just say
that
in in
in you know measuring blood pressure
it's it's it is it is some observational
way of doing it
uh so yeah that's that's the way i would
see it
our next question is uh
can you break on the translational
potential of single cell omics and how
categorizing the heterogeneity of cells
will help them targeting the tumor as a
whole
well that's a that's a great question um
so when we talk about trials uh it has
to be so single cell as a diagnostic is
is still very early there are some
trials going on but what we are doing is
we are trying to understand
can single cell help us to
understand the mechanism of action of
certain drugs so their single cell is
used uh quite being used right now uh
where we're trying to understand
uh the role of
different
you know similar blue types and all
those things mostly electronic setting
um
what what what cell picks up because the
effects are pretty low right that's
where the single cell is actually
helping a lot now cell type problem is
actually cell type heterogeneous in
terms of tumor
is is is a is a it's a very interesting
problem because you know it's an
uncontrolled growth of the
proliferation of the stuff i think there
are some very interesting paper that
came up recently in in drug tolerance i
think we should check on that i don't
recently i don't remember the name of
the author right now but there what
they're trying to say is your single
cell is actually trying to tell you when
you're giving uh in in tumor patients
particular solid tumor uh a particular
drug
how the drug is responding and what
cells are responding and what cell are
not responding i think this is one of
the fascinating thing to understand
whether the drug is actually being
treated by very some small small cells
that are responding to it and they are
actually reversing the disease so this
is how uh these things can help but this
these are still very open research
problems they're not only solved because
as i said the data is very very complex
and you know highly abundant so
it's it's not it's not something that
it's already solved we are still trying
to tackle these kind of massive problems
as an open research problem but there
are you know lips and bounds of work
that already going on